chandler was so overconfident he says oh
oliveira he doesn't have heart that's a
big insult
to say a man doesn't have heart he says
when
when he says when oliveira feels my
pressure
he's gonna question whether he uh
whether he wants to
to even fight he's gonna i'm gonna break
his spirit he's gonna have no gumption
oh man yeah really good for oliveira to
shut that [ __ ] up
you know you know what i think what what
happened is that when you do those
interviews
you promote the fight the interviewer
they try to
they they dig deep to try to make you
say
things yeah to talk [ __ ] about your
opponent
right right i don't i don't think you
underestimate
uh oliveira i think he was kind maybe
pushed to say something like this
because
fight are promoted on emotions right but
they are not
one on emotions fights are one on
mundane
stuff that you do every day in training
and uh
yeah i i a lot of time you have guys
that will talk a lot of trash
they play mental warfare yeah you know
and now
that was that was your last fight
michael bisping is that right yes
michael bisping was pretty good but he's
actually a very nice guy but when you
get into a fight
the fight start the minute you sign the
contract because now in the media
he's gonna make some crazy declaration
and
you're gonna have to prove him wrong in
the ring and stuff like that i remember
the press conference the the media
for for you and michael bisping and i
felt like oh
michael bisbang he he won the press
conference but then
you stuck it to him in the octagon yeah
but you know what what what was the best
promotion the best thing we did
promotion wise for that fight
it was not even during the press
conference and i have to give
i have to give it to michael bisping we
were in toronto
during a press conference and he was
talking [ __ ] to me and i was answering
back
back and forth and i cannot win a a a
a a trash talk conte contest
with an englishman because english is
not my first language
and on top of that i'm just not good at
it so
of course he was talking trash and stuff
like that and we made that we did the
face off and when we did the face off
he kind of came too close and he put his
hand on me and i pushed him back
so we went after the press conference we
went
our both separate ways and we went
backstage in the truck
and we were backstage and i remember
they were like
there were kids they were coming up to
meet for autograph
and michael bisping his car was is is
uh not as car as limousine was was
parked not far away from mine so
he saw me backstage and he saw that the
tmz was there as well
so he saw the camera the tmz camera so
right away
came into my face right away in front of
everybody and he says to me say hey
and you can you can check that clip it's
on youtube i believe you can check it
it goes like hey next time you put your
your 30 yen
on me i'm gonna i'm gonna swing at you
and i told him something like yeah like
go ahead right now let's do it right now
and then we
we got separated by by the michael
bisping coaching
so but people really like were
really tuned in into this and and these
kinds of stuff
makes the emotions come coming out
and people want to buy the fight because
fights are promoted on
emotion right so bisping is a very very
clever guy he knows how to promote the
fight
did you know that when you had that
fight that he could only see out of one
eye
no i did not i did not i mean i knew i
knew his
his vision from one of the one of his
eye was compromised but i didn't know it
was like that i mean i didn't know it
was a hundred percent like that it's
insane
yeah he's probably the toughest guy in
the ufc
ever i mean tony ferguson tony ferguson
has been racking up some tough points
yeah
yeah it's true tony ferguson tony
ferguson
michael bisping is not too far behind i
gotta say right
right it's called stevo's hot sauce for
your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon and buy stevo's hot sauce for
your
butthole yeah
yeah dude